Okay. Um, we're going to pivot here
slightly. Uh, at Texas, what happened in
Texas with Governor Abbott the other day
declaring the Muslim Brotherhood in care
terrorist organizations and restricting
them on their involvement. Uh, we are
going to be on this every day. It's
absolutely essential and want to give a
hat tip to Governor Abbott and his team
for for doing this. Understand there
took a lot of pressure from the
grassroots, but it's done. I asked uh
Raymond Ibraham who I think is with John
Guandola. Raymond is one of the top
experts in this. First off, when you've
got a new book out, I want to tell
people about about getting your writings
on this topic of Christianity versus
Islam is is the best out there. Um, the
importance of what Governor Abbott has
done. I tried to do this when I was in
the White House at the federal level. I
got zero traction on this. I mean,
nothing but beat back from uh from the
State Department and others in the
intelligence apparatus. Why is what
happened in Texas so important? Raymond,
>> it's definitely important because it's
first of all, it's very unprecedented as
you just indicated and it's something
that had needed to be done for decades.
Uh the Muslim Brotherhood and by
extension CARE is a terrorist
organization. This isn't Islamophobia
and we know this by the simple fact that
Muslim countries ban the the Muslim
Brotherhood as a terrorist organization.
This includes Egypt, uh the United Arab
Emirates, uh Saudi Arabia, Syria when it
was under the secularist Bashar,
probably not now, under the al-Qaeda
leader. Um so, first of all, this is a
terrorist organization. It's the oldest
Islamic organization. Um it it formally
renounced terrorism sometime in the 70s,
but before that, it was engaged in
assassination attempts, for example,
against the Egyptian president G Abdul
Lasser in the 50s. It has the the
primary theoretician of jihad who is say
al-Q who was writing so definitely a
terrorist organization and all it did is
it actually changed this modus operandi
from physical jihad to more of a
subversive jihad. So for example I think
in 2009 uh when care itself was named as
a co-indict co-indicted uh terrorist
organization in the largest terrorist um
the holy land fund I believe it was
called. um they captured documents and
in those documents it said we are here
in America the Muslim Brotherhood and by
extension CARE and all these other
organizations to wage a civilizational
jihad and the reason and the way they
would do that is by subverting and using
America's own laws and and and to
subvert the United States and enforce
Sharia. So when when governor Governor
Abbott mentions that they want to spread
Sharia and people think this is
hyperbolic, it's not. Their own
documents say that. Okay, so this is
something that should have been done a
long time ago. They exist ex care exists
exclusively to use the word Islamophobia
to shut down anyone who who who exposes
them. Uh lots of people have come under
fire. I myself was attacked by them on
numerous occasions. The most famous was
when the US Army War College invited me
back in 2019 uh to speak about one of my
books and they went ballistic and they
called them racists for having me on.
They called me a racist. I'm Egyptian
and of course I'm Islamophobic etc. And
the and the US ar Army war college
buckled to a terrorist organization.
Okay. But of course afterwards lots of
pressure came on them including from
Congress to bring me back on and they
eventually did. So it didn't work. But
that's all they exist to do is to shut
down uh the truth and hopefully more
states and ideally the federal
government will follow suit because
there's no controversy here whatsoever.
I I want to just go back for a second
and talk about you talk about the you
know you've got the Persians in Iran you
got the Turks but in the Arab nations
Egypt and Saudi Arabia you've got other
great Arab nations but they're what is
it like the Muslim Brotherhood has is
dedicated to the overthrow of the
governments in Egypt and the government
in in the monarchy in Saudi Arabia and
this is why UAE I would argue one of the
best allies we've got in the region
right is uh it MBZ dead, understands the
dangers. What is it like to be in an
Arab country uh and have the Muslim
Brotherhood every day trying to work to
overthrow those governments and actually
uh put Sharia as the law in those
nations. Sir,
>> well, that's exactly why these countries
ban them as a terrorist organization.
And it's not easy because they have to
walk a fine line because uh these Arab
countries and these Muslim countries
can't say we're banning them because
they want to impose Sharia. Okay? rather
they point to the fact that they're
engaged in terrorist acts and those
governments pay lip service and often I
mean Saudi Arabia does enforce Sharia.
Okay. Um and uh Egypt and Sharia is
enshrined in its constitution article 2.
So that's the issue is in Muslim
countries uh the Muslim Brotherhood of
course is seen as a great organization
and it wins people over through sort of
grassroots level reach out. It engages
in charity and zakat with fellow Muslims
to try to bring them into the fold. So
that's it's not a very uh it's not as as
cut and dry as it is for us in the west,
which is the irony because those
countries, the fact that they do ban
them as a terrorist organization, puts
them at risk because they're attacking
fellow Muslims who for all intents and
purposes appear pious and want to
enforce Sharia, etc., which the
government also pays lip service to. So,
it's ironic that we here in the west uh
are are are are hesitant to do this uh
against an alien organization that as I
said was captured on multiple occasions
declaring that their intent purposes in
the United States is to subvert it and
enforce and impose Sharia and and you
know a final point about Texas
especially that I think a lot of people
are missing about this big enclave this
epic city and whatnot um of a thousand
homes and I don't know how many
properties is I I find it ironic. Why is
it Texas that they're doing this? Could
it be because of the poorest border? We
already know that amongst all the
millions that cross over illegally are
Islamic terrorists. So, I do wonder why
they chose that state to create
basically an enclave. And I'm wondering
is it so they could actually be there
and try to manipulate that border for
their own and to bring in their own?
you know, John Guandino, who we've had
on, uh, Guandola, and also, uh, Raymond,
I I've had them on since my Breitbart
days, 15 years ago. Raymond, you warned
at the time when I used to have you on,
we your books, some of your books are
first coming out, that um, you warned
about England and you said, "Hey, in
these industrial cities where they're
starting to take over the the center
city, they're going to put Sharia courts
up there." You were one of the first to
warn against Sadi Khan. And people
laughed at us. You see right now I say
the threat is in New York City with
Mandani and it's in Texas and you can
see they're very they're very smartly
and in a very cunning way trying to take
over the financial capital of the world
and they're trying to take over the with
the greatest uh the jewel and the crown
of the United States. Your thoughts sir?
>> Yeah well you know looking I always say
look to Europe to see the trajectory
that the United States is on. You know
they're more progressive than us in more
ways than one. In other words, they are
they are an example of where we're
headed. Um, you know, the UK, this has
become a joke. Uh, they've got these
enclaves. The idea of an enclave, by the
way, I've been I'm writing about this
because it's very important. It actually
in Islamic terminology and theology and
history especially, there's this concept
called Rabbat. And a Rabbat is an
enclave of Muslims that actually uh is
that actually develops along the borders
with non-Muslim nations. So what how far
the jihad goes and it's stopped by
non-Muslims. There they build
fortifications which become you know
breeding grounds of on the one hand
piety and jihad. Okay. So they they're
there to to you know be good Muslims and
read about and study and practice jihad
on the infidels across the way. So when
you look at these enclaves that's
precisely what they are in this
potential you know epic city in New
York. That's what they are. They are
breeding grounds of radicalization from
whence these people then go off and
terrorize the infidels. You know the UK
we can think about um Sweden Malmo I
mean that's now become a bastion of
Islamic sentiment and jihadist rage and
whatnot. And this is all around in
Germany and it's growing in Italy and
Austria, France, Spain and you're always
getting these attacks. So these enclaves
aren't just uh you know non- assimilated
foreigners. They're actually jihadists
and that's part of the Islamic law and
the Islamic cannon. So when we come here
and look at the United States, the only
uh difference is the US has a small much
smaller population of Muslims for now
compared to Europe. But it's like I
said, it's on the same exact trajectory
what with with what's going on in New
York with what was about to happen in
Texas and we got what's going on in
Michigan and you know all these dearborn
etc. So we're definitely on the same
track but with this latest development
uh of you know calling out the Muslim
Brotherhood for what it is and care
terrorists I think that's you know some
good news.
>> Uh you you've got another your books are
amazing. Our audience loves them. You
got another massive book coming out I
think next week or the week after. Talk
to us. Two swords of Christ. What What
is it? Uh and why should why should our
folks buy it?
>> Yeah, it's the two swords of Christ. Um
here it is just to give you an idea. And
it's literally about the two military
orders that most combed um Islam for
five centuries which are the knights of
the temple and the knights of the
hospital as you can see on the p the
pommels of the sword. And you know,
their history has been so warped. The
Templars are now, you know,
unrecognizable. They're, you know, these
esoteric non-Christian,
you know, forerunners of the Freemasons.
All of which is nonsense. And I debunk
it and I'd show all the facts against
it. But it's really if you like sword
and scimitar and if you like defenders
of the west this is really the
culmination because on the one hand it's
a history like sword and scimitar of
their war against uh Islam and like
defenders of the west it the the heroism
exhibited often onto martyrdom is
unparalleled. Um and again these are
stories that you know you'll never see
this in Hollywood. Hollywood creates
fake things that are supposed to be her
heroic and epic. This is once again
proof that truth is more heroic and more
dramatic than fiction. If you read these
stories and they're all very well
documented, over a thousand endotes, all
mostly to primary sources. Um, so again,
you're I think people will be very
inspired to see that and and the most
important thing I think is that I really
show you how that they understood
militant Christianity is not a bad
thing. They were all about just war
theory.
>> Raymond Hanger for one second.
>> Two swords. Two swords, by the way, real
quick. is the is is Christ two swords
>> in Luke.
>> Um I hang on because I want to give all
your courters. I know you got to bounce.
It'll just be a minute or two.
>> War room. Here's your host, Stephen K.
B.
>> Uh Raymond, I want people to get this
book. Next Tuesday, Raymond's going to
join us for an entire hour at six
o'clock. We're going to break down the
books. This is And I want you to get
this book. Get these books if you to
young people, particularly young men.
This is the story of the two fighting
military orders of Christianity monks
who were warrior the warrior monks and
I'm telling you it is reads like a
novel. Uh Raymond where do people get
the until next Tuesday sir social media
your site and where do they get the
books?
>> Uh best place for me is just my website
raymond.com r a y m o n d i b r ah h i m
and it has everything there. It has
links to the books um and all sorts of
things. You can get a signed copy if you
like and the book comes out like I said
Tuesday. You can order it right now.
Easiest place probably to get it from is
Amazon. Um but yeah, it's already a
bestseller on Amazon.
>> Okay. Of course, all your books are
bestsellers. The audience loves you.
Raymond, love you too. Thank you. And uh
thank you so much for your
>> observations on Europe, uh the Middle
East, and particularly Texas. And this
is for backup for Governor Abbott.
Everybody did this. remember Egypt, UAE,
and Saudi Arabia and MBZ out of UAE. He
doesn't mess around with this stuff.
They're a terrorist organization. He did
the right thing. More about that in the
days and weeks ahead. Thank you,
Raymond. Thanks. We